what is the Philosopher's Stone in the
late 17th century the Philosopher's
Stone was the most sought-after gold in
the world of alchemy according to the
legend the Philosopher's Stone could
transform ordinary metals such as copper
and iron into precious ones like gold
and silver it was also believed to be an
elixir of life with the power to cure
ones illness and even grant immortality
to those who possessed it
there are many descriptions of the
stones appearance the most well-known
being a red stone it was also referred
to as an orange stone when the stone is
in its solid form it often appears as a
transparent and glass-like object in the
shape of an egg there are many sources
that believe the Philosopher's Stone may
not have even been a stone at all when
searching for the stone alchemists
examined countless substances this would
build the base knowledge for fields we
know today as chemistry and pharmacology
many of the world's brilliant minds
search for the Philosopher's Stone
over the centuries including Roger Boyle
who is considered the father of modern
day chemistry even Sir Isaac Newton
mentioned the Philosopher's Stone and
some of his work
when discussing the philosopher's stone
the one name you will not miss is
Nicolas Flamel Flamel was a French
bookseller who lived in Paris during the
14th and 15th century in 1382 thermal
claimed to have transformed lead into
gold after decoding an ancient book of
alchemy we most likely will never know
if this was true
however the historical record show that
Flamel did come into considerable wealth
around the time he made his claim and
donated all of his riches to charity
it was after his death that Flamel
became so heavily associated with the
stone there are those who believe that
having achieved immortality Flamel faked
his death and continued his work on the
stone fans of JK Rowling's Harry Potter
will recognized Nicolas Flamel and
Philosopher's Stone as they feature in
the first book and film with it
originally be entitled Harry Potter and
the Philosopher's Stone the concept of
being able to turn metals into gold
attracted the attention of many over the
years who saw the legends of the stone
as a chance to make a fortune rudolf ii
the king of bohemia found himself in
financial difficulties and decided to
invest heavily in the search for the
Philosopher's Stone large amounts of
alchemists were funded and promised
hefty rewards if they could find the
secrets of the stone rudolf was never
able to find the stone become an insane
in the process he was later death rowned
by his relatives it is not known if his
madness was due to natural causes or the
misuse of toxic remedies that he
believed to be the philosopher's stone
one of the most famous frauds
was Edward Kelly who claimed to have
possession of the Philosopher's Stone he
had small amounts of white and red
powders which allowed him to turn heated
mercury into gold
Kelly did enough to convince Rudolph of
his claims and receive large amounts of
support and money eventually Kelly's
magical powders would run out lead in
Rudolph to jail him in his tower he
would later die from injuries sustained
attempting to escape the tower the
Philosopher's Stone has intrigued
scientists for centuries and even to
this day remains a mystery if you've
enjoyed this video then please go ahead
and leave it a like consider subscribing
if folklore mythology is something that
interests you if you have anything you'd
like to discuss or have any ideas for
future videos then please go ahead and
let me know in the comments below as
always I've been your host mythology and
folklore explained